[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres de l'actualité dans le
département lui dit y a suspendu son
soutien à la candidature de françois
fillon pour la présidentielle la
fédération du département s'est
rassemblée à la mairie de versailles ce
week-end pour débattre de la stratégie à
adopter
nous étions sur place hier les
intempéries ont entraîné l'annulation
des animations du village installé à la
mairie de bois d'arcy à l'occasion du
départ du paris nice tu les
installations dû être démonté en urgence
une météo qui n'a pas empêché le public
de se déplacer et puis ce week end a eu
lieu la première édition du festival
électro chic organisé par versailles
grand parc la scène électro versaillais
était à l'honneur parmi les artistes
présents qu asus danger ou encore agar
agar
mais on ouvre ce journal avec de la
politique de plus en plus isolé françois
fillon a décidé de maintenir sa
candidature
alain juppé est finalement renoncé
aujourd'hui être le plan b lui dit de
son côté annoncé le retrait de son
soutien la fédération des yvelines s'est
réuni ce samedi pour débattre de la
stratégie adoptée soit un candidat
centriste mais je vois pas vraiment au
jour d'aujourd'hui qui le ferait mais
pourquoi pas ça peut être une
une décision rapide et ultime soit une
hémorragie vers emmanuel macron vers
l'abstention est donc forcément si c'est
l'abstention c'est en faveur du front
national et de marine le pen ça va de
soi que donc c'est ce serait la pire des
situations non nous on milite pour que
effectivement françois fillon se retire
de cette élection
assez rapidement pour clarifier les
choses très très rapidement je suis prêt
à soutenir la nacre en fait je soutient
emmanuel macron il est pour moi un homme
de gauche et je ne suis pas un homme de
gauche je suis un centriste convaincu
donc je ne soutiendrai pas monsieur
macron premier tour la question du
deuxième tour et un est une autre
question
je vais dire qu'au premier tour je
choisis et au deuxième tour et bien
j'irai dans l'intérêt général de la
nation et comme je te soutiendra bien
évidemment jamais la candidature de
marine le pen il est bien évident que le
candidat au deuxième tour si je dois
traître monsieur macron il aura mes voix
mais j'espère bien évidemment ce sera un
candidat de la droite et du centre qui
sera présent au second tour pour se
battre contre marine le pen
la première étape de la carte scolaire
dans les écoles des yvelines sera mis en
place dès la rentrée 2010 est une légère
baisse des effectifs est à prévoir avec
une diminution de 230 élèves au total
149 mille cinquante sept écoliers sont
attendus et afin de répondre aux besoins
de cette rentrée 76 emplois seront créés
mercredi dernier une conférence sur
l'adoption organisée par le nouveau
service interdépartemental des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine a eu lieu au
théâtre de londres à vélizy villacoublay
cette cérémonie a permis de faire un
point sur un sujet qui touche plus de
neuf mille familles par an en france
le nouveau service interdépartemental de
l'adoption des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine existe depuis le 1er
janvier 2017
grâce à cette mutualisation de
compétences il est devenu le service
d'adoption le plus grand de france car
il concerne potentiellement 3 millions
d'habitants nos deux départements ont
fusionné leur service adoption et
c'était l'occasion de faire passer un
message
ce service de l'adoption qui est
désormais le plus grand de france je
pense qu'il peut participer à faire
évoluer la législation dont on voit bien
qu'elle est tout à fait adapté et donc
le fait d'être le plus grand peut
permettre d'être le plus innovant et que
cette innovation fait diffuser sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
l'adoption dans les deux départements
représentent 300 demandes en 2016
184 dans les hauts-de-seine et 116 dans
les yvelines
des demandes qui engendre souvent une
procédure de plus de neuf mois
avec ce service le président du conseil
départemental des hauts-de-seine patrick
devedjian souhaitent les s'amplifier
dans le processus d'adoption ce que l'on
peut déplorer
c'est là sur administration et la
déshumanisation dans dans l'adoption il
ya un juste un mot dont on n'entend
jamais parler et qui le mot essentiel
c'est le mot amour dans le dans la
démarche
ça c'est presque un conte venant d'en
parler pour l'année 2010 est le nouveau
service d'adoption dispose d'un budget
de 100 2000 euros pour simplifier vos
démarches l'organisme a mis en place le
site questions de famille dimanche les
intempéries ont entraîné l'annulation
des animations du village installé à
bois d'arcy pour le départ du paris nice
mais la météo n'a pas empêché le public
de se déplacer dans le village on la
ferme et aujourd'hui ils étaient ouverts
hier il a bien marché mais aujourd'hui
on l'a fermé parce qu'il ya trop de vent
et ça peut être dangereux tout le
centre-ville de bois d'arcy et ai plein
les gens sont venus braver les
intempéries
ce sont de vrais passionnés des amateurs
aussi beaucoup d'associations les
commerçants ouverts aussi pour
travailler aujourd'hui donc c'est la
vraie fête et puis très honnêtement
pense plus la météo pense vraiment la
course
un saint quentinois honoré jeudi soir
dernier et ricardo s'est vu remettre
l'insigne de chevalier de l'ordre
national du mérite
le fondateur du pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux ou encore du pavé dans la
mare à elancourt s'est vue honorée de 40
ans de travail autour du métier du lit
un retour sur cette cérémonie avec
mélanie poken cher et riz au nom du
président de la république et en vertu
des pouvoirs qui nous sont conférés nous
vous faisons chevalier de l'ordre
national du mérite une médaille pour un
visage incontournable du monde
littéraire saint quentinois et rijkaard
un libraire de profession a reçu jeudi
sa médaille de chevalier
je crois que depuis 30 ans que je fais
de l'activité syndicale c'était un des
points essentiels est important d'avoir
exercé des fonctions de président de
syndicat de la librairie française et
puis également président de la
fédération internationale des libraires
donc là il y avait une reconnaissance et
puis ensuite je pense également pour la
réussite des trois librairies pas mais
qui ont quand même marqué ces deux
lignes nouvelles
sur les trois librairies deux sont
encore en activité
le pavé dans la mare à elancourt créé en
1975 et le pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux
fondée en 1989 et ricard d'un c'est
aussi un engagement syndical 14 ans au
sein de la fédération européenne des
libraires pour moi c'est vraiment le la
récompense de toute une carrière
professionnelle je pense que c'est
amplement mérité et j'étais très fier de
pouvoir remettre cette décoration est ré
cardin qui depuis 40 ans
est une voix qui compte dans la
librairie indépendante française est
quelqu'un qui a toujours innové
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais eu peur des
révolutions des évolutions de notre
métier et ricard d'un a pris sa retraite
en 2014 les pavés sont toujours là celui
du canal est aujourd'hui gérée par son
gendre et c'est officiel depuis le 22
décembre les cinéma cyrano et roxanne de
versailles pas sous le giron du groupe
gc un rapprochement qui permettra
notamment de rénover les salles et de
proposer de nouvelles offres
les détails avec camille lambert le
cyrano de versailles aux couleurs du gc
c'est une nouveauté depuis début 2010
est le groupe a racheté la salle en
décembre il s'est associé à marie-laure
couderc nièce de l'ancien propriétaire
des lieux un partenariat établi sous la
société les cinémas de l'ouest
ce cinéma pour moi c'est le cinéma de
mes grands parents de mon oncle et même
de mes arrière grands parents
donc c'était important pour moi que ce
que ça reste un patrimoine familial mon
grand père a longtemps dirigé le gc a
travaillé longtemps avec le président
actuel et quelque part je retrouve mes
valeurs et également voilà donc c'était
un choix assez naturel pour moi
de choisir ses partenaires la juger
c'est pour mission d'assurer la gestion
et la rénovation des salles le cinéma
sera rendue plus accessible aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
des travaux ont déjà eu lieu dans
l'accueil pour le moderniser
c'est une restructuration lourde toutes
les salles seront concernés par la par
le projet l'ambition si vous voulez très
clairement c'est de faire du cirano
j'allais dire un cinéma de référence du
centre-ville de versailles
donc ça c'est ma quelle histoire ainsi
la gare non il ya une forte notoriété
finalement ce sera un cinéma ugc avec
une enseigne d'essayer la carte unité
tout vin tout leur savoir faire au
niveau de la programmation le groupe
souhaite donner plus d'importance à la
version originale pour les habitués ugc
se veut rassurant il s'engage à
conserver le caractère généraliste et de
proximité du cirano et refermons ce
journal sur une note musicale nous
étions ce week end au festival électro
chic organisé par versailles grand parc
l'événement dont c'est la première
édition mettait à l'honneur la scène
électro versaillais incarné par les
célèbres casus et danger aux côtés de
cette tête d'affiche des jeunes artistes
assurent déjà la relève
un reportage d'anne laure leur dire à
respectivement 24 et 25 ans clara et
armand forment le groupe
agar agar une musique électro propre pop
et dansante où le reconnaît l'influencé
des années disco mais aussi entre autres
celle des daft punk
au jeu de l'interview le duo qui
s'élançait fin 2015 se montre beaucoup
moins sage alors agar agar ça vient d'où
c'est une histoire que je raconte à peu
près 15 x 15 interview précédente qu'on
a vu le dos comme l'a raconté parce que
ça fait plaisir
vous pouvez pas s'appeler armand et
clara parce que c'est un petit peu
laconique
alors du coup je sais pas on a cherché
un petit peu des mots comme c'est un peu
au hasard
moi j'avais sinon qu'ils étaient restés
sur la langue agar agar parce que c'est
j'utilisais dans une recette pour
nourrir mes fourmies ce que je fais de
l'élevage de fourmies et du cou du coup
j'ai proposé à clara et puis on est allé
assez vite dessus dans leur duo armand
apporte la touche électro clara les
sonorités rock garage mais les deux
étudiant aux beaux-arts se laisse
volontiers influencé par d'autres formes
de création jeu d inspiration dans la
peinture dans la mare dans les livres
on marque on s'arrête pas là musique
pour composer musicalement leurs
chansons écrites par clara sont inspirés
des rêves de la jeune fille et ne
cherche pas à dire mais plutôt à faire
ressentir au public des émotions
donc ça raconte pas vraiment d'histoire
mais l'ensemble devient très bref
psychédélique on met des images les unes
à côté des autres et on voit si ça
déclenche des émotions intéressante si
oui on garde sinon auteur d'un ep de six
titres agar agar devrait prochainement
sortir un album
des débuts donc très prometteur pour ces
artistes qui refuse cependant de se
projeter bon mais pas trop devenir comme
tous les jeunes de notre génération
non ce pas non la vigne un bon awards
l'avenir est aux gens qui se lèvent tôt
je vais devenir
on n'a pas de venir
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]